welcome back today is world circus day  and circus circus is celebrating the  vegas way the resort is holding all  kinds of fun family-friendly events  today the trampese act the flying poemas  is performing as well as the  world-renowned america's got talent star  uzair neruzov and his free laddermen act  all kinds of carnival food also  available along with a bunch of new  games  we always look for new stuff new ideas  new performers up here in the midway we  are constantly refreshing the games we  just got a really cool new atv ride game  and some cool car racing that really  moves you around and feels like you're  actually driving a race car it does  sound fun all of that fun ends tonight  so head out if you want to take part